[Music]
everyone my name is Spencer Althouse and
I have had body image issues body image
issues body image issues for pretty much
my whole life I've had a love-hate
relationship with my body and with
fitness I did not think I deserve to
feel or look good and I have worked on
myself so much since then
it all started three years ago for
BuzzFeed I did this fitness project I
wanted to gain as much muscle mass as
possible in 12 weeks and by the end of
the project I gained just over 20 pounds
which is pretty incredible but it was
fun too and I have learned so much on
that journey and since and I've
struggled a lot too and I think it's
really important to talk about that and
it's important to acknowledge that
everyone's bodies and experiences are
different whatever you want to do I just
wanted to talk about things that helped
me get fit and stay motivated because I
have learned so much and I think no
matter what some of these things can
really help you so I think the number
one thing that I learned in the last
three years is that you need to listen
to your body your body is the most
important thing to you and if it's
telling you that it's physically and
mentally drained you should take the day
off there was one day last week when I
didn't complete all hundred pull-ups I
don't know it's just super tired my body
was exhausted no one needs to be working
out seven days a week no one needs to be
killing themselves at the gym if you're
sore or you're tired it's okay to take
that rest your body needs to recharge
anyway there's nothing wrong with it
there's no shame in taking some time off
your body will thank you and you will
get that necessary rest and then you'll
come back and kill the next day don't
feel pressured to tackle fitness and
nutrition at the same time this is a
complete lifestyle change for me so
going into this thinking wow I have to
literally change everything that I'm
doing everything at the gym everything
that I'm eating to sort of sets myself
up for failure you just think about all
these things that you have to change so
I took it one step at a time I did the
fitness first and then as time went on I
learned more about nutrition I learned
about things that I could substitute
with my meals what I should be eating
all the macros and all that stuff and I
think doing that
really helped because I learned that
small consistent changes are key rather
than just diving in and literally
altering my whole life I am in a rut at
the moment I sort of feel like the
biggest fraud in the world right now
because I'm making this video about
fitness tips and how I stayed motivated
and how I got fit and all that but I'm
struggling so much right now feels like
I'm not really taking my advice and it
sucks but for me the way that I've
really helped myself get out of that
funk is by creating these fitness
challenges so I drew 30-day fitness
challenges for BuzzFeed I'm gonna be
trading like a gymnast for 30 days doing
a hundred pull-ups everyday for 30 days
these challenges they really help me get
back into it because it's sort of a new
project for me to focus on when you
think about your fitness journey you
think wow this might be like a forever
thing you don't really have that sense
of time in your mind two more days left
I can't believe this is almost done it's
hard to really focus on something where
there aren't immediate goals in your
future so just finding new ways to
challenge yourself as a way to sort of
change up your routine is super helpful
what a lot of people think about healthy
lifestyles they think about the foods
that they can't have I don't like to
think of anything in terms of a diet
that feels super limiting it feels like
that's a negative connotation to me so I
never used the word diet
I just think healthy living healthy
lifestyle there was a time a few years
ago when I was super stressed
overwhelmed and I thought every single
meal had to be super healthy and I had
to do it a certain way and then I
realized this is absolutely ridiculous
I'm not enjoying this whole journey that
I'm on so for me I never wanted to pride
myself of my favorite foods I love ice
cream I love pasta I love ramen and life
is too short to not eat your favorite
foods so teach yourself about what's in
the foods that you're actually eating
but don't obsess over it so it took me a
while but I realized I'm not gonna be
able to cook every single of my me
and that is okay sometimes I'll be at a
restaurant maybe I'll make substitutions
to make my meal healthier and maybe I
won't none of that is going to kill you
none of that is going to undo anything
that you've done at the gym you like ice
cream eat your ice cream just finished
my morning workout and I gotta say
something that I really really try and
stick to is working out in the morning
early in the morning ready for the
challenge it is 6:30 in the morning if
you like I make healthier decisions
throughout the day because of it if I
worked out after work there's just so
many distractions people want to get
drinks or dinner or something after work
and I'm more likely to skip the gym so
going in the morning
definitely helps out and also I think
I'm more conscious about the things that
I'm doing later on in the day I'm more
likely to take the stairs or eat
healthier but this cake looks so good
just because I've already gone to the
gym and I just think starting off your
day with a morning workout probably
inspires you to be a little healthier
later on instead of setting unrealistic
lifestyle goals for yourself focused on
making achievable lifestyle changes if
you want to gain weight lose weight
that's great but what's also important
for me is to create a lot of goals for
myself that aren't strictly about the
numbers of pounds that I've lost or
gained I learned that it was really
important for me to focus on smaller
goals as well one of those things for me
is my flexibility before I started a
couple years ago you know I could
probably barely touch my toes now I can
do it with my whole hands on the ground
your progress isn't just about a number
that's on the scale so there are so many
things to celebrate throughout this
journey and to focus on outside of your
larger fitness goal I got this shirt a
little while ago and I've
her being so frustrated that it was too
big on me and I put it on today and it
fits very well so yeah like there's
obviously progress that is being made I
think that's awesome clothes are
starting to fit me better instead of
comparing yourself to other people
online or at the gym really just try
comparing yourself to your old self this
is obviously easier said than done
because sometimes I go to the gym and I
see people who are they it looks like
they have achieved what goals I want to
achieve and I get frustrated with myself
but that's actually super unfair because
who knows maybe they're on your ten of
their fitness journey and I'm only on
year three so I try and just compare
myself to my older self I don't know I
just keep thinking two years ago I
literally could not do a single pull-up
and now I'm doing 100 at a time and so
on days when I am feeling no motivation
at all I can think oh wow actually I've
come really far and I've done a lot so
that's super helpful I hate running I
don't like it I never understood it
that's great if you love running good
for you that does not make me excited
about working out so it's super
important that I do find things that I
actually like about it maybe that's rock
climbing or taking a gymnastics class I
started doing gymnastics for a BuzzFeed
post and it's a new sort of workout that
I would never get at the gym normally
it's a full-body workout cardio heavy I
feel like it's probably better than
running and I will never get tired of it
and that's what you need to do you need
to find an aspect of working out and
fitness that you actually enjoy that way
it doesn't feel like you're working out
when I was taking gymnastics classes I
never thought I have to work out and go
take gymnastics I have a tumbling class
tonight which I'm really excited about
just get out of my tumbling class
and I love it so much I really wish that
I did gymnastics when I was younger
finding that new aspect will inspire you
and motivate you in a way that you
weren't before no matter how many
followers you have online I think it is
so important to post about your fitness
journey there
it sounds good as super to say but there
are a bunch of people out there who are
super interested in what you're doing
who might be going through something
similar and they want to talk about it
and they want to push you forward
posting about your journey online helps
you hold yourself more accountable for
me when I post about going to the gym or
about struggling at the gym or about not
knowing what to do we're not feeling
motivated sometimes when I'm at the gym
I'm like oh I have 70 more pull-ups to
do I just check Instagram it was like oh
well there's five more people who are
like oh you can do this I'm so proud of
you whatever so sort of like a buddy
support system I think it's super
helpful to post about your journey
online you can see the progress and you
can talk to people who are going through
similar things and most importantly I
really just would suggest that you be
patient you're not kissing changes
overnight and that is totally fine
but you will be hitting goals along the
way I could barely do a cartwheel when I
first started this in 30 days later I'm
doing Randolph back tucks
I am super proud of myself for following
my fitness journey and I never really
thought that I could do it I was not one
of those people who really enjoyed
working out before this looking at
myself now I was in your shoes and I
probably still am but I am not a
professional athlete I'm not a personal
trainer I'm just a regular person who
wanted to change something about himself
and it is incredible and all it really
took was some determination a desire for
success and a lot of hard work but like
you you can you can do this it's not
like the hardest thing in the world it's
super overwhelming because you're
tackling nutrition and fitness and all
these other things but it's so worth it
in the end
is incredible for me to go and feel
comfortable and confident at the gym
when I never did before and now I can do
a pull-up which I never could have done
I can do a flip there's just so many
things that will blow your mind that you
are able to do that you don't think
you're able to do now this sounds so
cheesy to say but a couple years ago I
really wasn't liking myself for how I
looked so I started working out and now
I'm able to do like these things I never
thought I'd be able to do and you can do
that too if that's what you want to do I
work very hard for it in a
what I'm able to do now just take your
time take it one step at a time
and you've got this thank you so much
for watching the video if you want to
hear more about my journey check out the
article that I wrote for BuzzFeed in the
description below
[Music]